okay all right so I was mistaken I was
supposed to jump at four seventy six
which I had an inkling to do and you're
supposed to hit a block that I guess
Falls that at the sky and somehow hurts
you and gets a spring and continue so
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
holy crap that's awesome so anyway that
was really cool and this person made
some incredible levels but I'm gonna
move on and play a different creator's
levels because I want to see like all
the different things that people have
made so I'm going to the second most
popular person and Mewtwo strikes back
automatic sounds interests oh my
goodness oh wow oh okay okay so this
person apparently makes automatic levels
but this one has an enormous amount of
stars I don't even know if it is
automatic its Pikachu staring into my
soul intro quiz I love this quiz isn't
in Japanese because I'm gonna be oh oh
wow I don't know what I'm supposed to be
doing but I imagine I'm gonna fail
horribly because that's kind of my
wanted life hello oh okay hello
that's a splatoon character which is
nice and all
and that's Kirby do I want to be Kirby I
don't know what the question is how can
I fail good for me I don't know what I
did
oh the music oh I'm supposed to guess
what game the music comes from
was that dr. Mario oh no failure and
dance I don't know this
oh man that one was hard to discern it
must have been Pokemon in some way with
the one game that I don't actually pay
and play much of which means that this
music coming up right here yeah yeah
that was definitely yeah that was so
cool it's so cool sorry ok yeah oh oh no
there was a thing ah damn it okay oh
that's yeah yeah I don't even need to do
the other ones because that's one of the
original Mario's oh that's so cool I
don't know that one I can't listen to it
again I want to say Mario Kart maybe
Mario Kart oh so close
see I don't play much of splatoon so it
might have been the splatoon one oh I
get a chance to do this hello
oh gosh I don't think I'm supposed to
come down here cool
my trap for all eternity now okay thank
you
I'm glad I came over here this wasn't a
waste of everybody's time sorry dad
everybody oh man but this is such
interesting level design here I don't
have much else to say besides that no
that was yeah oh sorry yeah of course
oh cool Mewtwo how many different
characters are there in Maya maybe
because I'm not entirely on like 100%
sure now that I hear it I think I
recognize like you from you cuz I
watched Aaron play a lot of splatoon I
didn't play it myself because I was very
bad at it but
that was amazing that was absolutely
amazing oh so cool ah that was well done
some better vocabulary because I always
just say oh that's so cool
how does someone even do that why am I
just what did I flatten down like a
pancake I have no idea really cool that
was really cool I need better words than
really cool okay so I'm gonna go back
I'm gonna shift gears I'm gonna try to
find a difficult one so what I need to
do is I need to find a creator who makes
very difficult ones and not just
automatics oh god I didn't ask for that
point zero seven percent clear rate all
right let's give it a go I don't know
who this is
there's a faceless mass murderer
probably I'm probably not gonna have a
fun guy scared me caught me off guard
okay well if that's how we're doing it
good God you cannot be serious with this
but I triggered the thingamabob er
doesn't mean that I almost got it how's
anyone supposed to be able to do this Oh
expect to be done holy crap so it is
possible
right who that is don't believe in me at
this point this is friggin impossible
how would anyone even have the
perseverance to even try this one time
I'll never be able to get it again in my
life so stupid I'm not prepared to
succeed I just expect nothing but
there's nothing to be oh god I gotta
jump high enough but it's impossible
because okay you know what I'm gonna do
this differently I'm up with two fingers
only two fingers on this because if like
me holding down the Run button and
happen to press this bag of ass I just
want to get through it once more I don't
even want to beat it I just want to get
through this one part what is it so hard
why am I wasting my life doing this is
obviously the stupidest thing anyone
could do I can't even get this again
I might do this one and win so I can
feel accomplished about my life about I
can feel good okay all right
I can't even feel satisfied about doing
this freaking stupid Mario [ __ ] crap
ass so thank you everybody so much for
watching my name is ben markiplier i'm
gonna remove my name from my name and
call myself dick bag dick sucker so
signing off from dick bag m'q dick
sucker this been mario maker
have a nice day everybody sale on sale
strong